بعد قتال عنيف منذ اشهر باتت مدينه بخموت
رمزا للنزاع بين الروس والاوكرانيين من
اجل السيطره على منطقه الدومباس تزعم
روسيا انها حاصرت القوات الاوكرانيه في
المدينه ومنع الدخول اي تعزيزات اليها
القوات الجويه تدعم القوات المهاجمه وتعيق
ارسال احتياطيات الجيش الاوكراني الى
المدينه وتمنع انسحاب وحدات العدو
من جهتها نفتكييف هذه الانباء مشدده على
انها تكبد القوات الروسيه خسائر هائله
تضارب الانباء لم يقتصر على النفي
الاوكراني فقد صرح رئيس مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه ان من السابق لاوانه الحديثه عن
تطويق كامل للمنطقه
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تواصل ارسال
رجال من الخلف ونقلهم الى المدينه تنتظرنا
اصعب المعارك واكثرها دمويه ومن السابق
لاوانه الحديث عن تطويق كامل لبخموت
بريطانيا تحدثت عن هجوم روسيا جديد على
بخمه على مدى اليومين المنصرمين ماده
الانسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه من مواقع
التره للتنازل عنها في الاشهر الاخيره
تقدمت القوات الروسيه شمال ضخمه وجنوبها
وقطعت الكثير من طرق الامداد الاوكرانيه
وسيطرت على الجزء الشرقي منها وتتقدم منذ
ايام في وسط المدينه تؤكد كيف ان مقاومتها
في بخمه اتحدث بيت الجبهه والقضاء على عدد
كبير من القوات الروسيه الا ان خبراء
يشيرون الى ان المعركه الاطول منذ بدء
الغزو الروسي لها ايضا تكلفه كبيره على
الجيش الاوكراني